the Joe Rogan experience Nigel bans
fighting again I know he's eighty
thousand years old fifty-five it's
really 554 yeah
how is he doing who's he gonna fight um
I've heard Sachi Oh Becca
really Joe main policy I remember him
because how old don't know don't know
he's probably in letcher right Jones
knocks him out Denis sorry little PK
yeah back in the day yeah and you know
another thing he fought box him as well
Joe Calzaghe a is there any foot see if
this footage of Nigel been training
recently like I want to know what his
body looks like 55 man he's in shape no
but I mean well you remember that fight
with Gerald McClung way back in the day
back one needs to have the dreads
yeah and that was that was like the
defining fight where people realize like
oh god a guy who's the elite of the
elite like Jeremy Clements terrified of
him that's why I got into hypnosis fruit
for boxing and sport is because Nigel
Benn after he fought gel on McClellan he
said I'd like to thank Paul McKenna for
hypnotizing me like making me believe in
myself yeah yeah I went to an evening
Nigel Benner said I got into the job the
career that you that I do now through
you so your influence well he certainly
needed it in that fight yeah yeah belief
in himself I thought it got stopped in
round one when he would fill out a real
when it's known a couple in know what no
to come and yeah it could have easily
been co-opted McClellan was some murder
he was murderer is this day one back he
posted this on Instagram let's see oh
[ __ ]
he looks [ __ ] great [ __ ] their
colleague I really feel like [ __ ] man
but they're on a piggys county tech it
can he take hard can he hold his shot
that that edge did not mean well he
looks [ __ ] great in like when you
watch them throw punches you see Ricky
Hatton on pots look at the speed man a
55 that's crazy
they could punch out as well so knowing
a bit it's not been them shorts which
almost like lead you to piss into this
Cup sir yeah
we're buying into it though I don't want
you coming from someone who's on trt
yeah
buying it that's amazing man
that really is another video of him let
me see here it's loaded they're working
on some combinations here but I mean it
don't look bad at all like if someone
told you that got dirty yeah someone
told you that guy was thirty you'd be
buying it I mean that it's crazy that
he's able to maintain that speed it's
got a son called Connor Bennett boxes as
well is it well away a zombie 55 is old
oh man that's [ __ ] old it's to be
fighting another man like like that type
of yeah the only thing that I would
think is well one thing going forms that
he did not fight for a long-ass time you
know I want to see what he looks like
without a shirt on - that sounded gay
but it's not I'm just at purely as a
person and analyzing but even back you
buddy dude used to fight all these
fights with crazy walls yeah do you do
you don't know about a long time off but
do you ever recover from mice right and
how much do you recover when you get hit
him right back I mean he last fought I
want to say 15 years ago how long the
last time he fought was against Steve
Collins well I lost my 20 years ago more
than 20 years ago yeah because he's been
in it was in it got into he's overly
into the church then him and his wife I
think his name's named Caroline they
live in Australia he actually used to be
arrived at PI animal Danny buck in there
it in his book and I says it he'd have a
fight and then he'd go out on a Friday
night and he won't come back until
Monday he used to do DJ in a stuff LA so
he were popping pearls and doing all
sorts out all weekend and he wouldn't
stop and still until the Primeau rang
him and said right got fight in ten
weeks
yeah need to smoke 20 cigarettes a day I
need to stop and go back into campus
right away but his hands are like that
I've met him and a big picture with me
turns like that big he's massive his
hands a huge that certainly helps yep
what I'm seeing there that's so shocking
is his speed yeah that a 55 he still got
that kind of speed and eats what he
wants he says don't be anything it is
not a good diet it's just he says I eat
what I want what I feel like but he
trains
all the time my rooms like 10 miles a
day in yeah well I'm interested yeah I
got me a window kid not like I'm a
little confused though when he says he
eats what everyone he's not following a
good diet like I would imagine that if
you're gonna be at like Bernard Hopkins
late in his career like he was an
anomaly but you attributed it to his
discipline yeah when you know lived the
life yes
I don't like anyone else and yes aside I
wonder I mean if Nigel's not doing that
how the [ __ ] is he able to I mean I mean
he might be doing it now but what'd ya
say he looked well and look if he's
fighting for a fight camp yet he might
do it now boy when I win it scene
interview with are you fishing keep
scary I'm not bothered you know eats
what he wants honey it's fine you bunk
what got me like what boxing one of the
best fighters I think my 82 you back
forever cuz I loved him as well hated
him some bags it was great far he was a
great fighter you know it's just it's so
weird to see a guy come back at 55 it's
so confusing
I want to somewhat fall I mean [ __ ]
bored and obviously you can still crack
yeah you know that's you probably like
my kid figure I can do this yeah yeah
though if I got to that age you know I
hit the path [ __ ] you know people's I'm
is coming back yeah you can see the
wheel spinning
[Laughter]
[Applause]